alors risque permanent
on peut considérer que depuis le temps
qu'il ya eu des prises d'otages et que
le gouvernement français a informé tous
les gens qui vont dans la zone que ce
soit des touristes ou des professionnels
qui viennent travailler le risque de
prises d'otages s'est réduit mais il
existe toujours parce que on peut
parfaitement avoir un groupe terroriste
qui fait un raid et qui va aller dans
une ville même dans la capitale on l'a
vu au burkina faso ça peut arriver au
mali ça peut arriver ailleurs pour
prendre des otages
en plus les otages si vous laissez une
monnaie d échange qui vaut très cher sur
le marché et donc ça intéresse aussi
lorsqu'il s'agit de se refaire une santé
sur le plan financier pour les autres
terroristes et aussi d'ailleurs pour
quelques groupes plutôt voyous